you
[Music]
so I know I don't have a lot of time to
talk so let me just sort of get right
smack into the middle of this I was
asked to talk about urban and
transportation related things but I sort
of talk a little bit more broadly we are
a think tank based in sri lanka history
of you know we're about 12 years old but
very much in the sort of ICT policy and
regulation space but then we started
looking at how can i cities be used in
other sectors so agriculture was one of
those and then since 2012 we've been
working on big data trying to use that
for specific developmental policy
domains but the work is only in sri
lanka and a little bit in Bangladesh so
these are some problems of interest to
us cities very much you know we
understand that given the region that we
are located in large amounts of the
population is in the cities and they're
growing at tremendous rate which is you
know not in the most planned fashion so
what can we do in that scenario when
there is limited planning and limited
sensor data that we can bring to bear so
primarily what we're thinking of is
using data from mobile operators as a
proxy faz
as human sensors for a lot of different
things these are the four areas of the
research practice that I lead that that
it looks at one is conducting the
analytics for answering specific
problems in different domains or to
develop insights that are fed into
specialists working in these domains
deeply engaging with the policymakers we
actually in a way come from the other
side not so much from the analysis side
but given our historical linkages with
policymakers
and working in that space trying to work
with them and the symbolic environment
so not just a policymaker
but you know in that specialists the
domain of transportation which can be
broadly defined also studying the
impacts of it for on society privacy
margin
realization competition issues so we you
know we do have sort of our founder is a
lawyer as well so you know that that's
the area that we sort of look at quite a
bit just because it's also an area that
sort of can counter some of the work
that we are doing in terms of trying to
limit the impact and we want to sort of
bring evidence grounded in reality into
that discourse in on a regional level so
that for example we've convened with
sort of regulators in the region we sort
of talked to them on a real regular
basis also with ITU and the related
bodies in the regional apt for example
in trying to make access to telecom data
more easier for others in the region so
and developing guidelines so I'll just
give you some examples of what we're
doing with CDR data everyone knows what
CDR data is so this is essentially your
meta data every time you use your phone
so when you make a call receive a call
send an SMS receive an SMS initiate
internet session do a reload these get
automatically created in the network
that the operators have this data and
this is meta data so there's no actual
content and we've got basically for
about half the population of Sri Lanka
ten million plus people's through
multiple years record sudhana mais so we
don't know who they are we don't know
what demographics we don't know
economics it's just a mass of people
people's data so using that for a
variety of things trying to get more
granular and high frequency estimates of
population density understanding changes
in population density the dyno cycles
circadian rhythms of people moving into
and out of cities in terms of these
traces that they leave behind and these
do have implications for example this in
terms of transport what you see here is
this is Colombo City and the picture
shows you know the relative density of a
place relative to midnight so what it is
like at 6:30 twelve thirty six thirty in
the
evening and so this is a weekend weekday
so during during the weekday noon that's
when you have sort of you know Columbus
City's population density is highly
saturated and you know the people are
generally coming from the regions
outside the city so you sort of have a
sense of where people are coming from
what the population sort of hotspots are
and you can start to thing use this also
as a way to understand cities there's
this thing about whether cities are mana
centric polycentric what does that mean
for urban planning this is some of that
that insights that inform that debate
also when you think about what's the
what should the administrative boundary
what should the limits of the city be
Colombo is actually a very small City
compared to India Indian cities we are
technically the population is 550,000
but daytime population is excess of 1.5
million so you can start to think they
all back or they're all imposing costs
on the city that aren't recovered from
transportation to garbage collection etc
so what should be the optimal makeup of
cities what should the boundaries be and
you can start to play around with
interesting sort of possibilities that
you can do with policymakers about what
should be the makeup of the city where
you can start to increase the boundaries
to a certain manageable population that
is still manageable in terms of services
that can be delivered to them so we sort
of so engaged with policymakers on
issues like this on transportation for
example we are sort of trying to think
this is essentially what we do is
because of all the traces that people
leave behind we can construct a network
of mobility and we are doing modularity
optimization to sort of do some
partitioning of this and so what
essentially this means is that this is
each colored region is a region where
the density of travel within it is
greater than across and you can think of
this being plugged into last mile
solutions right if you have the bus
that's coming from point A to point B
where should the this would be where the
three-wheeler associations you might
want to have
can think more broadly and think about
sort of local localized transport
schemes for park-and-ride options based
on where people start and where people
end up we are also for example studying
the impacts of new infrastructure this
is work that I do with Joshua
blumenstock from the University of
California UC Berkeley where we are
looking at developing new measures of
trying to understand the impact of new
infrastructure on mobility and by
extension understanding the welfare
impacts on the population over time
because if we can have this data can
understand it short term medium term
long term impacts this is something that
we we're doing right now the the field
work we just got completed we don't have
a lot of intelligence about this 10
million plus people we don't know gender
we don't know economics we don't know
demographics so what we're trying to do
is an ideal scenario we would work with
the operators to do phone service
through which we can build a good
training data set but that's a little
difficult to accomplish so we're doing a
slightly next spec solution is sort of a
parallel activity where we've done used
a purposive sample and installed found
people with mobile phones make sure
there's enough coverage of gender age
and economics socio economics level that
they are in and have an app that
captures their cell phone behavior as
well as you know we do a survey on top a
sort of be capturing GPS logs as well
from these smart phones but in order to
build understanding for transportation
policy we are asking questions every so
often so between the time of 6 a.m. to 9
p.m. we are asking every hour on the
hour questions like you know where are
you what are you doing where I feel
going where I going to and what form of
transport you are using
through which we can sort of we
basically leverage this as a training
data to understand the mass of data that
we have on the other side with the the
cellphone records but again you know
this data is sparse it's not great for
understanding traffic conditions
there's vlr data which is good but
that's not kept for very long in the
networks it doesn't give you a very fine
temporal resolution so we are trying to
develop algorithms to do CCTV footage
working with the police department
they're also trying to understand for
example based on the circadian rhythms
of people connected to base station can
we again identify regions of high
economic activity and sort of understand
whether you know on the highly
residential to highly commercial
spectrum of areas but that is not good
enough so we are also looking at
satellite imagery to understand urban
space a lot more that's more the idea
being that you know trying to have you
can make all these grand plans and
visions of what your sister should be in
20 30 years but when you don't know
what's actually happening on the ground
it's kind of pointless so but we can
also leverage mobility this is basically
using an Origin constrained gravity
model to develop new ins proxy
indicators of economic activity
these tracked very well with nighttime
lights but they have the added advantage
that you know this is at finite temporal
resolution you can think about doing
this weekly you you know I mean this is
a great measure of understanding on a
very localized basis so like yesterday
we're talking about regions at a
district level but here you can
potentially go down even further down so
this is work in progress that we're
doing and we're feeding into the sort of
official statistics these are the sort
of broad implications of this work that
we are working with different different
domains so urban and transportation
policy epidemiology unit on
understanding disease propagation
yeah so that's in a brief the kind of
work that we're doing thank you
[Applause]
so when we started this there was
absolutely no demand we sort of were
under the radar by purpose because we
didn't know we needed to be said we had
to figure out all the implications so we
didn't talk about it for a good year and
a half it took about a year to negotiate
the data so initially I would have as I
was saying to some of you I was like a
Jehovah's Witness going door-to-door
have you heard the good word of big data
but now it's more like like you know
they will give us calls we are doing XY
and Z so there was a huge amount of
policy enlightenment work in the
beginning doing workshops doing meetings
to tell them the different ways of you
know that you can use this for so now
it's at different levels so it's not
always that the senior person knows a
policymaker knows all the interactions
that the department is having with us so
large amount but there's health for
example is more tricky we're still
working with them we're working with the
police department but you know that's a
long engagement of having chai pani for
a long periods of time
[Applause]